do you get dressed for the Grammys in a  different way than you do for different  red carpets this actually like an  out-of-the-blue type hair and we were  like you know what like I want to do the  short blonde I wanna do something  different I was like well it's like it's  my style oops like yo let's do like a  mullet  okay a little Bowie yeah it's totally  Bowie what about new music from zendaya  like what's coming you know only know so  much about life with that Amy knows only  so much you can speak about  my own finding about more about myself I  think that is kind of the experiences  I've been able to talk about and  actually know what I'm talking about now  you